vaccination is gathering speed across
europe
it is now essential that our economy
which was badly hit by the pandemic
also recovers rapidly and we have just
entered a crucial phase
for our recovery and for the future of
our union
we have 750 billion euros
from our next generation eu recovery
plan which we need to invest
rapidly and this will boost our social
market economy and
power our unique single market it will
enable europe
to come out stronger from the crisis
right now the governments of eu
countries are finalizing their national
recovery and resilience
plans and the commission works hand in
hand with them on the plans
round the clock because we need to
target these investments
carefully to make europe fit for the
future
in the following weeks we will translate
the recovery plans
into legal texts we know where we want
to get to
because we chose our objectives together
as 27.
we want to build a green europe which
protects our climate and our environment
and which creates sustainable jobs
we want to invest in a digital europe
innovative and competitive in global
markets
and we want a resilient europe which is
better prepared
to face future crisis we have 750
billion euros to build our future union
this is the opportunity of the century
for europe
a truly historic moment the commission
will ensure that these plans
reflect our high level of ambition
we owe it to our citizens and in
particular
to our young generation